going to another court case that we're
following the second Alex Jones
defamation trial has now started
there's a great article on Reuters which
we are linking to it's an explainer
what's at stake in Alex Jones second
Sandy Hook defamation trial now we
interviewed plaintiff's attorney Mark
Bankston a few weeks ago who uh already
obtained a nearly 50 million dollar
judgment against Jones in the first
defamation case and now is representing
plaintiffs in this second case as well
very important uh items here about this
case this is the Connecticut case as
it's being called it started this week
13 family members of Sandy Hook victims
as well as one FBI agent are seeking
damages from Jones and Free Speech
systems for claiming they were so-called
crisis actors lying about their
relatives death as part of a
gun-grabbing conspiracy by the United
States that's what Donald Trump that's
Donald Trump that's what Alex Jones
claimed initially about Sandy Hook
that's what this is about okay
then we get to
the next uh trial which started
yesterday and in yesterday's trial Alex
Jones new attorney did an impression of
Alex Jones himself now I am not a legal
scholar I am not a legal expert I don't
know
that this early in the trial doing an
impression of your own client shows that
you're heading in a good direction maybe
later in the trial the impressions are
appropriate check out this wacky video
[Music]
kill them I went into the school Bam Bam
Bam Bam shot each one of them yeah
that's right when I go out on the street
people forget Adam Lanzo was the killer
they think it's me
it made Escape go to Alex Jones
the lawyer in doing an impression of
Jones
seems to be using that video where Alex
Jones Goes Nuts to show how much of a
victim Jones actually is here now of
course what his lawyer was referencing
was this completely insane interview
that Jones gave Andrew Callahan a couple
weeks ago remember this do you feel
responsible for what happened to the
Sandy Hook families yes I killed the
children but beyond that no I mean I
went in that school I pulled a gun out I
shot every one of them myself I mean I'm
I'm I'm guilty it's true no but no no
let's just do I feel responsible that
someone on on the play video games on a
bunch of drugs went and killed a bunch
of kids and then the internet questioned
it and I covered that no I don't feel
responsible and I don't apologize
anymore I'm done
I don't apologize I killed the kids
was there a defendant no I killed him I
killed them all right anyway so that's
what was being referenced there so the
trial clearly not off to a good start
and then here's another moment from the
first day of the trial I believe this
was the first day judge Barber rebellis
sanctions Jones because yeah he refused
to participate in Discovery this was an
issue in the first trial and it was an
issue in the second trial and here is
the judge saying you're not
participating in Discovery I'll make the
following observation this suddenly
Cavalier attitude with respect to
their Discovery obligations is what led
to the default in the first place the
defendants have consistently engaged in
dilatory and obstructive Discovery
practices true from the infection of
these cases
right through to the trial and finally I
will note that is there is no notice in
this file
to this minute of any supplemental
compliance producing the Google analytic
documents which is required by the
practice booklet was also required by my
clear court order of September 30 2021
which apparently was not followed here
so the motion is denied
for these reasons and the
Court hereby sanctions the defendants by
precluding them from presenting evidence
or argument that they did not profit
from the Sandy Hook coverage there you
go uh Judge Barbara abellas not not
pleased with what it's going is going on
so listen in all likelihood this will be
another disaster for Alex Jones but
we're not going to prejudge it it's just
the most likely outcome we're going to
follow the case one of our sponsors
today is Bluetooth a unique online
service delivering the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's supply for free so if you
think you could benefit from an extra
boost of confidence when it's time all
you have to do is take a short quiz on
their website a licensed doctor approves
your prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA the entire
process is just a few clicks go to
bluetooth.com the link is underneath
this video they'll give you an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code Pacman all you have to do is
pay five dollars shipping